>> JSConf EU JavaScript and the microphone.
And control it and do some analysis. As a result, of the icon and because of I had
I find there are amazing people interested
in stuff. And so many of them created a group
like live: JS. Thank you, JSConf EU, for giving
me the power to believe in myself. To speak
in front of people. To see that failure is
something and only exists to let me grow.
Thank you for being you.
[Orchestra music playing]
We’ve come so far, and we've reached so
high
And we want to stay
[Synth keyboard playing over drum beats]
[It's very catchy]
[The music stopped!]
[ Applause ]
>> You might wonder how we ended up in this
situation.
>> So, yeah. Hello hello JSConf. We
>> Woohoo!
>> We want to show you how this stage was
built. And I would love to get the slides
now, please. As everything is working. So,
yeah, there should be slides. And the title
of this talk is how no making of the stage.
And yeah. The second slide says
[ Laughter ]
Oh, there it is. Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Yeah, you see? We don't practice anything.
We just do everything live. Oh, so the clicker
is also not working. Yeah. So, we have live:js.
We consistent of, yeah, different people.
The core team consists of Jan, Martin, Matt,
Ruth, Sam, and myself. And we would like to
explain how all of this is working or not
in a small presentation. And I will give the
microphone now to Zach. Actually, the clicker.
>> Thank you. Hello. So, we prepared a very
easy to understand overview for you about
what has happened since about November. We
were like planning this.
So, basic this is what you know. You see this
is kind of the stage. And you might remember
the beautiful presentation of the curators
you saw today. A nice keynote. And the keynote
didn't work because, you know, keynote restricts
the width to something like 4,000 pixels.
We needed to take something else. Keynote,
please. Obviously not PowerPoint. So, we took
Google Slides. They allowed us to get the
8,204 pixels that we needed. And basically,
that was our first little hurdle that we overcame.
So, in this presentation you might remember
many people have already worked on this presentation.
Including me doing some background graphics
for that. Which also was quite a pain because,
you know, if you put in Google Slides, SVG
wouldn't work so you have to go over the EMF
files, which is a vector form of very old
time and so on and so on. That was already
a little bit complicated but actually worked
out fine. And, of course, in such an intro,
you want an opening title. We asked our beautiful
friends to prepare some animation for us for
which they needed Illustrator files and they
did some after effects magic with it. And
the after effects magic went into like the
moving, and the JSON files. And the JSON files
were exported to SVG files and that's what
you basically saw in JS. And you also saw
a beautiful live video from Ruth and Sam that
went in and you will see and enjoy today some
more. That is Canvas and WebGL.
And all of this including all the slides
to make it work in the browser because that
was what we aimed for. And that was our concept.
And then you heard also beautiful music also
made for the browser with web audio from Jan
and Matt. And this music actually came from
Sam. Thank you, Sam. And everything is here
lighted in color theme and rhythm item with
his custom interface that he did using DMX.
Thank you, Sam. And, yeah. That's about it.
Then we also saw a wonderful beautiful image,
because what is JSConf without the opening
of the audience's programming and for the
tenthanniversary we had something very special
going on here. That was made with WebGL and
a beautiful also live WebGL presentation in
order, well, you're guessing it, to work in
the browser.
Yeah. And somebody had to pull all of this
together, thank you, Martin. So, somebody
has to take all that stuff and bring it into
the browser and switch between stuff. Doesn't
always work fine. But it was a sweaty job,
Martin did it. And we had help from Paul who
went up the stage and checked our performance.
We actually succeeded in doing a good job.
Thank you, Paul. But then Paul broke our browser.
But that's okay. Happens sometimes. So that
was basically in short very easy to understand
a nonchaotic overview about what has to happen
to do this. Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Yes. So, this was kind of an overview.
So, now we want to explain the all the small
moving parts. So, what we got from JSConf
was a song that you heard. And, yeah, we should
make a cover out of this. And the only one
doing this stuff in our group is usually Sam
with his Game Boys. So, what he did is he
created the remix using this framework you
can actually see on the screen. And, yeah,
you heard it also.
And this is not enough. So, we also met or
Monday evening this week to actually have
tech week with the whole crew. And in the
end, we had like kind of this scrum board
with many, many tasks and hopefully the most
important parts are done. And one of the focus
things across was the intro. So, we actually
created some kind of timeline and to be sure
what we wanted to do. And we also wanted to
do more remixes because we have two more musicians
in our group, and they all want to play with
the music. And first of all, it's Matt. And
the second of all is them and they want to
talk about the stem cells.
>> Hey, I'm Matt. And the reason I'm here
with live:js and at this festival is because
in 2015 I was invited to talk about my web
audio and electronbased sequences sampler
and synthesizer that I made for my own personal
use. And gave a big talk in the Singapore
JavaScript conference. And then I met all
these wonderful people here. And we have been
hanging since. But in the meantime, I've actually
stopped using my software with WAV audio and
I've switched to using actual synthesizers,
samplers and drum machines. Because it turns
out that actual things are better than virtual
things. But, hey.
But for a JavaScript conference here, the
last JSConf EU, me and Jan thought that it
would be wonderful if we actually made a full
thing in WAV audio instead of just using our
hardware. One last time for you people. And
Jan's going to tell you all about that.
>> Okay. So, yeah. You can this is all open
source now. So, you can go there. You can
take a look. It's currently it's a little
bit hard to play. But we hope that we can
fix that at some point so you can just open
the website and play that. So, the brief was
to basically create a remix from that song
from Sam. And we, as musicians we have certain
softwares that we like to use. One of them
is able live, a professional like musicmaking
software and it was really easy. It's like
an IDE for song writing, basically. So, it
was really easy to do sketches. Much easier
than programming something. And so, we did
sketches in there. You can pull in the remix,
you can pull in audio, you can do all kinds
of things. But at some point, we had to, you
know, get this somehow in the browser. And
the main language that music tours speak still
is Midi. And Midi is not ring tones or something
for those that remember ring tones. It is
a very old protocol from 1983 which allows
musical instruments to talk to each other.
And it's still in wide use. You can see it
here on stage. It's great. It's reliable,
it's old, it's robust. Much different than,
for example, getusermedia or something. And,
yeah. And for some reason and I still haven't
understood why we now have web midi which
allows us to talk to midi instrument from
the browser. And so, what we could do is still
keep all of our arrangement enabled live and
send this to the thing that we've built over
the last four days or, so which is a combination
of different modules. It's a sampler. It's
a synthesizer. It's a playback device. It
has lots of effects. A whole bunch of things
you can take a look at. And all of this is
driven by Ableton live. And it's wonderful
because it also allows you to set cue points
and everything. So, we were able to switch
between different scenes of the intro and
we could also send synchronization data to
Martin's computer who would then play certain
videos or, you know, not videos. Not actual
videos but, you know, animations and 3D animations
and stuff like that.
So, yeah. That's how we built this. Take a
look at it. Yeah. And we hope we can give
you something so that you can play it back
on your own.
>> Okay. So, now let's come to the actual
setup on the stage. And this is where Martin
should come and say something.
>> Yeah. But I think I would just give you
some basic facts about the stage. As you can
see, it is big. The main screen is something
around 40 meters wide and 5 meters high. And
yeah. Okay. Doesn't work so well. So, we have
five projectors. They are perfectly aligned
to create one continuous image. And this one
image is 8,000 x1,000 round about pixels wide.
We run this from a single PC that has three
dual HD outputs. And so, it outputs like 11,000.
But we only have the browser window a little
bit smaller than that.
So, additionally to this big screen and the
projectors we have all these light panels
around here. 34 of them which are controlled
by software. And finally, we have this nice
little X over there which has an interesting
story behind it. Originally it was supposed
to be canvas and projected on. But then it
turnedus that projectors have sort of a
focus. So, we couldn't really project anything
sharp on it.
So, Matt had the idea to put it full of LEDs.
And we were almost ordering 200 meters of
these LED strips in order to make it work.
Until suddenly someone who would have been
responsible for soldering it all together
was like, wait. We have these these professional
LED panels lying around and maybe you just
use them.
So, these are 17 panels. Each of 192x192 pixels.
So, in total, much more than we could have
bought with LED strips. And it's controlled
with a single full HD signal which is the
full screen browser window as you might have
guessed. And those are the specs that we received
for this.
And it works surprisingly well. If you want
to create content for it, there is a CodePen
somewhere if you check Twitter, JSConf, you
should be able to find it. Where all of these
positions are already yeah hardcoded and
you can just like start doing that. We'll
probably show some of these at least tomorrow.
Yeah. And I guess that's it for me. Yeah.
[ Applause ]
Yeah. Yes, Ruth.
>> Yeah, sorry, the slide. It's not here.
So, next thing is this is Ruth.
>> Yeah, we'll just mention. She did do all
the design for everything as well as everything
else, by the way. So, yeah.
[ Applause ]
So, yeah. My software. So, I started building
a piece of audiovisualization software approximately
five years ago, I think? This was very much
an experiment. Like we got the web audio API
about seven years ago and I started analyzing
it and moving stuff around the DOM. I started
playing with SVGs. And this is a great idea
until you chuck about a hundred SVGs at the
DOM and analyze audio at the same time and
try to move them around. I quickly moved to
Canvas. But the software which I built, and
I have been building it for five year was
a tangled spaghetti code. And I was gigging
with it, mixing video to the beat, mixing
Canvas shades and crashing every five minutes.
It was a great experiment and I had a really
great time making it. But I came to this year,
it's probably a good time to start naught,
naught, point naught, one instead of naught
point naught, naught, naught version. And
it would be good to do one thing.
So, I started this year, and for the past
couple of weeks, especially during this hack
week, I have been basically been trying to
get it to a stage to use it for circumstantials.
Sam is doing visuals with me. It's got four
moving parts. And it's doing one thing. And
focus on my style as an artist. It's generative.
It basically just chucks some Canvas with
some parameters. I'm analyzing audio and using
midi as well. And it just generates visuals.
That's what I want it to do. No more video
or mixing, just visuals. And four moving parts,
colors, turn into palettes. I've got vectors
and turn into grids. I put some physics in,
I'm looking forward to that. And shapes. Shapes
are going make sprites. And when it came to
the X, Martin mapped the X to use the normal
screen. We knew where the positions were.
I made a CodePen with the coordinates of where
these positions were. For me, I was pretty
okay. She had made a grid system. I could
make a custom grid, just map the coordinates
of the X, right? So, if we take a look at
that. There's a great contentious with my
software.
All I have to do this is a normal visualization
going on. I can't see what's going on.
>> Yeah, it's working.
>> I just pipe in the coordinates and map
nice little squares like we saw for the opening
which actually didn't take too much effort
in the end. So, yeah. This is available on
GitHub. The URL is there. It is in a state
of getting it working for this conference.
But yeah. That's Bizra.
[ Applause ]
>> Yeah. So, that's powering the O and the
X. And we also have a software which is powering
the whole stage behind me. And Sam will talk
about that.
>> Indeed. Hello. So, yeah, I'm just going
to quickly run you through modV. And if all
goes well, you should be able to see my desktop
in modV in the center. The X is kind of in
the way. But never mind, hey. Hey, there we
go. Perfect. Thank you. So, yeah, this is
modV. Wow. This is a screenshot, the X is
in the way. But modV is an environment that
I have been building in the browser for I
think it's six years this year now. It's Canvas,
WebGL. It's all audio reactive. It's got a
whole module system which you can kind of
just drop in new modules. So, like if we just
did everything that's going on. We can just
kind of drop in, I don't know, some sound
calls.
And then if we just give it some signal through
the microphone. Yeah. So, you can kind of
see it going there. But then you can stack
this, and it's got a whole UI and you can
build modules for it. Yeah. To get this working
because modV has a plugin system, Martin sent
me the specs for the wide screen. So, this
whole wide screen is actually a 1080 signal
split into two sections. The top section is
the lefthand side of the screen, and the bottom
signal is the righthand side of the screen.
And with the plugins I could hook into the
plugin and spawn a new output window and that's
just actually running on another desktop here.
If I swipe, that's my desktop background.
So, yeah, this is just another browser window
for the software that I just kind of am tinkering
away at in my free time. It's all open source.
Go to modV.JS.org. It's all there. But, yeah.
That's a quick run through, really.
[ Applause ]
>> Yeah. So, now we are switching to the software
I'm creating, I have been doing this also
for five years now. And I'm controlling the
lights. And this is how my software looks
like. And it's it's getting its databased
on what we use as projecting. And you can
see in the top I have a grid of colors which
I get from modV and I'm mapping them to the
actual lights that you can see in the venue.
And now we'll just go over to my PC to actually
make sense of what I'm saying so that you
can see that the lights are working. So, yeah.
This is all also controllable by a midi
controller and I can just add kind of different
yeah. Visuals in modV and this is presented
live on the lights. Yeah. Which is pretty
cool. I think. And all of this is connected
to the XPort using a custom created web use,
and there's a controller. As you can see it
here, using an Arduino. And this is everything
in the browser. There's no server running
at all. Yeah. So, you can control lights that
are actual everywhere just with the browser
window which is cool. I think.
[ Applause ]
Yeah. And that's like how we built the stage
and how we worked together to actually get
you this live show. And you see there are
a lot of moving parts which could go wrong.
Especially if you're just using everything
in the browser. And to debate get you some
kind of goody, we released the song that Sam
created on Sound Cloud. You can find it on
his sound Cloud if you want to. Yes. And that's
it from the talk perspective. We will do now
the remixes and
the show again. So, have fun.
[ Applause ]
[Electronic music playing!]
>> Live:js remix.
>> Live: JS